the crowd behind castillo 1-2
poked in the air to right
castellanos bending back
at the wall makes the catch
and on many other days a great american
ballpark
that swing likely does damage he's had
some hard hit outsidely
and winker unloads deep right center
goodbye
destroyed by jesse winker his team
leading 18th home run at 109 off the
back
he's hit some balls on the button
nothing really to show for it the last
few games
the only people that are going to catch
that bar are the fans in the stands no
chance for the guy
yeah that was an excellent play and he's
made some great plays defensively at
third base
this time a little more routine that
throw nearly off line bottle with a
stretch at first base
it's not so easy
joey vado definitely on the base
like that might have been a little
cutter
payoff
grounded to india ranging right backhand
pick sets his feet makes the throw
castillo looks to the heavens
see strands graves at second and third
one-nothing mid-two
his own force of nature barnhart past
albies
that's in the right suarez up to second
barnhart's been coming on for about a
week enjoying a career year
farmers hit safely in five of his last
seven appearances seven hits in that
stretch
and this one on the ground to riley
second base one on to first it's double
play
two for the price of one and cincinnati
fails to add to a one-nothing lead and
we are off to the third
back in atlanta the pitch
is swung on and hit high in the air
toward left center field long run winker
diving try can't get it that ball's up
against the fence acuna on his way to
second and he will stop there so the
braves have their third hit acuna has
his 17th double and he represents the
tying run yeah look like a change-up got
in on his hands a little bit he was able
to fight it off and drive it a little
bit big lead for freeman who's
positioned for a running start it's like
he's out of the runners blocks sky to
center twisting around naked now curls
heavily toward the gap oh the wind is
pushing that ball he makes the catch tag
at second throw in eaten by farmer head
first slide into third of icuna two down
a bit at the corners that's the first
major wind ball we have seen today yeah
that ball was definitely affected by the
win austin riley is single to right he
wallops that one to suarez on the fly
great glove work by gino
the hot corner is hot
not a lot of time good reaction by the
veteran the poster player for that is
nick castellanos he is mr line drive
to produce hard contact like that right
there long drive to center nc art day
gathers india's helmet flies he stumbles
some
and he scores standing
the baseball leader in doubles strikes
again as castellanos
doubles the reds lead
[Applause]
well this inning is what you come to the
ballpark to see cassiano's with the
double drive in the run then joy vado
gets a chance to hit
drives in castillanos and they get to
challenge acuna junior right field with
the bullet to the plate a little offline
and strike three just struck out the
side that was beautifully done by ian
who said the reds are out in order seven
strikeouts
loops that one to akiyama ball to find
you right into the game sliding try
akiyaba holds on and makes the catch
that wanted to squirt free well the win
you mentioned the win first play into
the ball game and
my bad he made the play and used about
all of that glove
grounded to short diving stop by farmer
to his feet throws out of first in time
two down
shortstop on shortstop crime you really
don't like that but hey don't hit it
here you got all these other folks to
hit the ball too
don't test your shortstop
that's down the line and right
round of second by herrera castiano's a
strong arm windmill is on to third from
ron washington ending a relay to the
plate the ball is there bart hearts tag
he's out
brilliant relay execution castellanos
india barnhart
dead to rice
clicking on all cylinders
fundamental plays and the boys on the
field love it
already awaits on deck dansby in the
driver's seat pitch he takes ball four
and the braves bring the tying run to
the plate in the eighth inning
well last night was guillermo heredia's
night can he turn in a repeat
performance
hot shot and through there's a base hit
albie's around third he's gonna chug
home and score and the braves break the
shutout it's a three to one game there's
that ever elusive first hit with a
runner in scoring position her radio
back up to his late inning tricks again
we got a 3-1 game yeah ready just
continues to do good things
1-2
swing into this brock struck him out
two k's in the inning for brock
and he limits the damage 3-1 mid-eighth
we saw santana in the opener stevenson
gives that a ride straight away center
field
to the banners eye
the rookie goes dead center
and some breathing room for cincinnati
it's back to a three-run lead in the
homemade
so when do the young pups no longer
be referred to as young pups
reds up three
save situation enter a.g amir garrett
fisted pop
indian treks out
makes the back pedaling catch
one away
2-2
in the air castillanos holds his ground
leans in makes the catch
the reds are one out away tying run on
deck two outs two strikes
one two swinging a miss he struck him
out
slider away
and a fifth save for a g as the reds
win for the third time in four games
they dispatch to the braves four to one
[Applause]